serious one but I don't know if and
we'll talk about those not say Beyonce
and jay-z not standing up for the whole
I saw that I didn't see it let me see
did it stand for the national anthem
yeah national anthem hey this might say
you want district flag go somewhere else
yeah yeah that's one day me singing and
their families just sitting down what is
it is that but hold on hold on
so basically everyone else he's the he's
the connect yes to the the culture for
black people the NFL yeah he's the one
who's supposed to be the Kaepernick's
right-hand man he got cabinet two
workouts and all that [ __ ] mm-hm and
Kaepernick posted this I thought we were
past kneeling though yeah
so just reposted on his Instagram so now
Kaepernick is going at Beyonce and jay-z
so are we sure that they actually sat to
an anthem or did somebody take a picture
them sitting and then put it over the
anthem to create some concert that was
possible and that's could they not stamp
some weird reason like Beyonce's dress
or ass was blown up I don't know but I
mean most likely they were sitting
during the anthem so the reason why this
is the reason why this is stupid one is
because he said I thought were past
kneeling and two you know the cost of
that so every decision you make when
you're in public as a celebrity you are
aware of especially when you're an event
of this magnitude you know tat your own
camera so every decision you make is
calculated so if if it was
hypothetically if they did sit during
the national anthem they wanted people
to know they're sitting during the
enhances they know understand you want
it now that's a PR move exactly so if
you want people to know then J I don't
know if you're in the right position to
go to get to go to Kaepernick now we're
not kneeling anymore my feeling really
might yeah my thing with cap it's like
do something dude but do something bro
right you're not out third you know he's
not out there giving any sort of nice
awareness he may he gave a lot of money
gave a million away like he's he's been
about it cats been about it the tricky
thing was him trying to be in the league
again like that's one owner understand
it's like if this league disrespected
you this league did all this [ __ ] that
helps you out of it he did he's a
he gave a million oi know what you make
is a year from Nike sunny gave a million
dollars of his own money away like just
cash it's a lot of money bro hey [ __ ]
for him like in doing this this [ __ ]
well the aikikai contract yeah but he
has a new contract to them he's making
more money now than he was playing
football see I don't know if that's true
you don't think so I don't know I don't
think he is man I really don't I think
that's why he wants a play because at
the end of the day is like there's a
lovely game there's also a lot of money
comes in a game I think he's more
valuable not playing I think he is more
value to the cause not playing but I
think if he makes it about him playing
it distracts from the issue which he's
trying to raise awareness for and then
as far as like the anthem thing is like
my thing is so little it's just such a
little thing like you don't have to join
the military in America you don't have
to go to basic training there's like
literally no cost to being American
right like you pay taxes if you make
enough money but you get to live in the
best place in the whole world you get
the most opportunity to do whatever the
[ __ ] you want be it an entertainment
sports or whatever the whole world has
to come here you do interview outside of
soccer to like make money at whatever
they want to do and entertain their
sports or these types of things that the
whole you already your grandfather into
a novio nothing and then the cost is
like be cool just stand up for the aunt
that link yeah we're not even asking
that but you know you'll have to join
the army like in other countries where
it's mandatory service literally if if
they made a rule that was just like hey
can you just stand up for anthem artists
don't disrespect the the the flag that's
all you got to do a lot of people were
making the argument that it wasn't
disrespectful to the flag because cap
asked the the guy who's in the Navy was
like what were the Marine what was the
best way to go about this and the guy
was like wanted to take a knee because
the knee is like a sign of I'm
acknowledging it but I don't I'm trying
to raise awareness I'm not doing
everybody the whole thing is confusing
like if you want to boycott the police
then you do that at the police station
you don't do that at the NFL like it's
just you want a boycott brutality but
then you're gonna do it at the sport
that's the most brutal and what else oh
Jesus and there's so many things are
conflation there's so much [ __ ] it's
also like jay-z or if you don't agree
with their agenda whatever then I feels
don't you part of it don't go to the
game you're the one [ __ ] doing all
the [ __ ] for it
yes that's why I don't even think it's
real I don't know who knows and and
low-key and not only do I not think it's
real like I think it's
it's nod you get you got to know
[ __ ] of standing up they know
they know I don't know if that's real
fast oceans I can't fathom it's real
because like there's look for that here
and he went out on a limb like when he
went said publicly were past kneeling
when he said that public that was a big
statement he got a lot of flack for he
got a lot of flack for it
so I don't know I don't know I need some
more facts we should blow out her dress
or [ __ ] you like Beyonce I love
young ya BR Oh like your music right
like the way she looks what about the
voice you like that voice sure like the
talk like her sing to me yeah no not
singing talking she has a really deep
voice when you went to that I'm into her
you're into it you I couldn't go with a
deep voice I'm into Beyonce with a deep
voice you'll put up with a deep voice
because what up with sitcoms would be on
I'll put up with some [ __ ] to be
Beyonce's sign okay I'll tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]